bonjour je suis à lille je vais vous
montrer comment je vis presque sans
déchets ni plastique
on va commencer par la cuisine
sans plastique et le zéro déchet ça va
souvent avec le minimalisme
parce que finalement ça se résume à
consommer moins mais mieux pour mes
aliments secs
j'achète tout en vrac dans des sachets
en tissu lavable et ensuite je mets tout
dans des bocaux en verre alors le vert
il faut savoir que c'est beaucoup plus
sain que le plastique ou le carton donc
il ya aussi le côté protection de la
santé au delà du côté environnement ne
pas produire de déchets par les
ustensiles que j'utilise dans ma cuisine
sont aussi sans plastique
donc il faut principalement en bois ou
en inox puisque l'inox est un matériau
très sain et j'utilise aussi le tissu
lavable par exemple j'ai des petits
chapeaux à mettre sur le dessus des bols
pour éviter le film plastique pour
recouvrir des restes alimentaires pour
tout ce qui est produits de consommation
dans la cuisine autres de ce qui est
alimentaire
on peut faire ces éponges soi-même à
base de collants filés contis tout
simplement c'est une technique
extrêmement simple et ça fait une éponge
qui est presque inusable qui durent
littéralement des mois et qui est fait à
base de récup
souvent les cosmétiques qui sont
polluants pour l'environnement
le sont aussi pour notre propre corps
personnellement j'ai besoin uniquement
de 5,6 produits pour m'occuper de mon
corps et remplacer tous les cosmétiques
traditionnels
on a par exemple le beurre de karité
donc ça s'est acheté en boutique
biologique et ça va remplacer les baumes
les crèmes pour les mains les stick à
lèvres ça marche extrêmement bien ça
nourrit très bien la peau on a aussi de
l'huile de coco qui est naturellement
antibactériennes donc elle peut
remplacer le dentifrice par exemple ça
blanchi aussi naturellement les dents on
peut faire aussi son déodorant avec de
l'huile de coco en le mélangeant avec du
bicarbonate de soude très économique
très très efficace aussi on a aussi le
marc de café
donc là aussi c'est de la récup et ça
permet d'exfolier la peau du visage et
du corps de manière vraiment très
efficace est tout à fait naturel dans
les exfoliants classique on trouve des
micro billes de plastique
donc en fait l'agent exfoliant l'ebit
que vous trouvez dans votre exfoliant
s'est littéralement du plastique qui va
être très mal filtré dans les stations
d'épuration et donc qu'ils vont finir
dans l'océan
pour le ménage on a pleins d'astuces
zéro déchet aussi on remplace les
essuie-tout par des chiffons lavables
c'est beaucoup plus économique en plus
on remplace la lessive plein de produits
toxiques par la lessive en poudre par
exemple acheté en boutique biologiques
certifiés biologiques
on remplace tous ces produits ménagers
littéralement tous ces produits ménagers
par du vinaigre blanc mélangés avec de
l'eau il en a aussi l'indispensable
bicarbonate de soude la gelée acheter en
vrac mais ça peut aussi se trouver dans
tous les rayons et pis ça c'est vraiment
très efficace tout à fait naturel et on
a aussi un peu de duy l'essentiel ça
peut être du citron puisqu'elle est
naturellement antibactérienne et
désinfectante et ça vous permet d'avoir
la bonne odeur de citron et en plus ça
va désinfecter votre sol vos meubles etc
[Musique]
en choisissant les recettes les plus
simples les plus économiques
c'est la flf zéro déchet et le zéro
plastique va être accessible à tous si
chacun fait quelques petits gestes pour
réduire ses emballages alimentaires pour
réduire ses déchets organiques par
exemple c'est là que les actions
additionnées les unes aux autres vont
permettre d'éviter beaucoup d'impact
négatif